この蛇の例えの教訓のまあ今日はこれです
百三十四ページの一番下の段落です
アリッタというこの和室使いの息子という名前の人ですけども
まあ彼が欲 いわゆるまあ性的な欲なんですけど
まあそういうことは修行の妨げになりませんという立場をとっていまして
まあそれについてお釈迦様と比丘たちがまあ彼のこの邪見をね
なんとかしようかなと努力した話で終わりましたけどね
それでお釈迦様が注意するのは
ブッダの教えを大変気をつけて理解しなくてはいけないということなんですね
いろんなこの問題を起こしたりする可能性あります
ですから この決して仏教というのは
この自分の意見で 自分の解釈で
自分の好みで理解してはもういけないものなんですね
まるっきり人間考えていることとは違うんだからね
で 他の宗教の聖典なんかに書かれてるものとはまるっきり違うことを言ってるんです
で 他のどんな宗教経典であろうが
読めばわかるもんなんですよ
教えてくれる先生がなくても
まあ言葉さえわかればもうわかります
数学のテキスト読むってことは違いますからね
科学のテキストを読むとは
まあやっぱり科学を勉強していないとわからないし
あるいは先生に教えてもらわないとわからないんですね
まあそれぐらいの難しさも
大体はまあ経典 まあ聖典というものにはないんですけどね
仏教はものすごくすごい違います
それはもう教えてあげたってわかるものでもないんですね
思考がすごい 人間の現象的な思考とは関係ない世界のことを言ってますから
ですから お釈迦様は簡単にある例えで注意するんですね
この蛇を間違って捕まったら
蛇が自分の手を噛むでしょうに
蛇に噛まれたら その人は毒が回って死ぬか死ぬぐらいの苦しみになっちゃうんですね
ですから 経典もブッダの教えもいい加減間違ってとってはいけませんと
ほんの一部をとって一部をどうって自分好き勝手に解釈する
まあそれは蛇を尻尾で捕まったことになるんですね
そこはまあ仏教の歴史を見ると
まあみんな経典をね まあ誤って解釈したということもよく見えるんですね
それでお釈迦様が教えた教えとまるっきり正反対の仏教になってしまったのはそういうわけなんですね
お釈迦様がこの実体がないと
我がないと 永遠不滅のものがないんだと
もう徹底的に教えているのにも関わらず
この西暦一世紀になってくると実体論になってくるんですね
魂というものあるんだぞと
仏性というものが人間にあるんだよとかね
野良犬という何かこの心の中に大事な何かあるんだぞとかね
そういうふうなところまで言い出しちゃったんですね
それで結局 お釈迦様が絶対的な神っていう考え方は仏教では成り立たない
それはないと言ったら
人の教えを非難したことになりますから
もうそんな人の話にはもういろいろ非難したり批判したり
そんな時間はないんだからね
余計なことだからしていないだけのことで
でもお釈迦様の教えの中からもう成り立たないということがね
因果法則によって もう絶対的な因縁に関係ない何か成り立たないんですね
だから世界創造した神がもう因縁に関係ないんだと
初めからありきやと言ったら
何の因縁の影響もないものでしょうに
だったらその人にどうやって他のものに条件人間を作ることができるんでしょうかね
関わりはできないはずなんですね
だから神がいるとしたってのは
神にはものを作れないはずなんですよ
だからもうそれは因果法則をわかる人には簡単にわかることで
だから絶対的に何のもの
何ものからも影響を受けない人にとってはね
自分の頭で何か想像することできるんですかね
想像したっていうことは変化でしょうし
なんで想像するんですかね
そういう必要もないでしょうに
だから絶対的な神ということを考えること自体が
もう物事はわかってない人々の考え方なんですね
だからすごいこの即的な
もう原始的な思考なんですね
鶏は卵から出てくるんだから
卵は鶏から それ先はどこですか？と
それで元の原因を探そうとする
そうすると 誰かが先に鶏か卵か作ってくれなきゃ問題は解決しなくなっちゃうんですね
ずーっと探していかなくちゃいけないんだから
だから同じことで 今私が親いるんだからいたんだからいるんであって
親が親の親いた親がいたんだからいるんであってね
過去行って行って行って行っていくら見たっても
やっぱり誰かがこれ初めに作ってくれなきゃ
もうキリがなくなっちゃうんですね
だから そういうふうなものごとを見るっていうこと自体
最初から間違ってるんですよ
卵からヒヨコ生まれることはもともとなかったことなんですよ
だから 瞬間瞬間変化する過程で
ある瞬間である変化がある
次の瞬間で違う変化がある
だから前の変化現象と今の現象っていうのは連続性でしか関係ないんですよ
だから卵は卵で ヒヨコはヒヨコでまるっきり違うものなんです
卵を茹でて食べられます
ヒヨコを茹でて食べられますかと
もう羽やらいろいろついてるんだから食べられないでしょうに
だから栄養成分にたっても違うと思いますけど
だから卵からヒヨコが生まれるっていうことはね
まあそれはもう言葉としてはいいのかもしれませんだけど
種族的な理想としてはね
でも厳密に見るとそういうことではなくて
卵を産んだ瞬間からのその中で
次の瞬間でまた変わる
次の瞬間でまた変わるという
いろんな変化が起きて変わっていくんですね
それが変わっていく途中で
どんどんヒヨコっていうものは出てきて
またそこのまたもう卵の中にいるっていうことは不可能になってくると
大きく巣はなくちゃいけなくなってくると
もうそれを割って外へ出てくる
それからまた変化して変化して
今までに変化して死んでしまうちゃうということになるんですから
だから そうやってこの瞬間瞬間変化であって
別に誰かが作る必要はないんですね
だから現象は時間の過程において変化するんだということは
見られない人にとっては
まあこういう風に神が作ったんだという話になってしまうっちゃんですね
ですから まあそれはまあ
子供でも考える思考であって
決してこの高等思考っていうことではないんですよ
まあ小学生の一年生ぐらいの子供が
私とすごい喧嘩したことがあるんですけどね
やっぱり最初に誰かが作らなきゃ何も出てこないんだそうと
そういうふうなことを言って
まあまあ子供に理解できないんだからね
もっと勉強しろということにしておいたんですけどね
やっぱりそういうふうにも
もう小学生の1年生でも考える話なんですね
ですから このお釈迦様の話をなんとか取って
なんとか取って それはもう拡大解釈しちゃうと
もう結局お釈迦様は仏教でない
全く仏教では邪教だと思っている教えっていうのを全部仏教になってしまったんですね
そこで邪教になったところで
インド教から見れば まあまた似てるんではないかと
またヒンドゥー教はやっぱり仏教はヒンドゥー教の一部だよと
そういうことになってしまったんですね
ですから この尻尾で捕まるなよということを
お釈迦様最初からもう蛇を尻尾で捕まったら
もう刺されて死ぬんだぞと
解脱はなくなるんだよと
ことがまあ一応起きてしまったんですね
今日は 正しく理解しなさいと
でないと大変危険だよと
だから危険っていうのはこのヘビに例えるんだから
もう並の危険じゃないんです
大変な危険なんです いい加減に理解するということは
次にこのお釈迦様はこの筏の例えの説法をしようとするんですね
クッルーパマンオービッカレダンマンデーシッサーメニッパラナッターエノーガハナッターエ
タンスナーテサードゥカンマナシカロートバハシッサーメティ
で クッルーパマン クッルーパマンというのは筏に例えて筏の例えでということで
ダンマンデーシッサーメというのは説法しますというね
法を説きますということですね
筏に例えて法を説きますと
ニッパラナッターエ この法は筏が渡るためにあってね
同じく法も渡るためにあるものなんですね
ノーガハナッターエ ガハナッターエというのは
ガハナっていうのは取るという
捕まるということなんですね
掴むということなんですね
だから まあ捕まって大事なものは大事なものやという風にするんではなくて
もう渡るために筏に例えて説法するんだと
まあガハナっていうのは何か一応取ることで
はいはい ありがとうございますと
もう受け取りましたというふうなことではないんですね
それを使用して渡るための説法だと
タンスナーテ それを聞きなさい
サードゥカン よくマナシカロート
頭で理解しなさい よく理解しなさいと
マナシカロート マナシっていうのは心の中で処理することなんですね
お釈迦様の教えを聞いて
頭の中でいろいろいろいろ処理して理解しようという努力が必要なんですね
ただわかったような顔をしていたっても何も意味はないし
もうそんな簡単にわかるはずもないしね
よくもうわかりますよっていうのは
それはあまりにも大きな誤解でね
あまりにも激しい高慢なんですよ
ブッダの教えだったら
もうすごい素朴で単純でわかりますよとかね
言って 一番最初にみんなスッタニパータを読む
日本でも最初に訳するのはスッタニパータなんですね
それは私の例えで言えばね
ただまあ ちょっとしたおもちゃの車も作れない
テクニックない人がいきなり宇宙船作ってみようと始めることと同じなんです
わからないと思いますけどね
だから日本でこの仏教理解にものすごい邪魔になってるのはそれなんですね
いい加減で 誰が訳したってもこれ訳できないんです
スッタニパータというテキストは
パーリ経典ででもお釈迦様の時代ですぐものすごい大きな注釈書を書いたんですよ
難しいんだから それはどれぐらい古いかというと
注釈書ではなくて それは経典の三蔵経の中に入ってるんです
ということは 当時でお釈迦様もサーリプッタ尊者に時々偈を出して
あんたこれわかりますかと
一回サーリプッタ尊者にいきなりお釈迦様がスッタニパータ今の記録している偈一つ
一偈ですよ 私はこういうふうな言葉を語ったことありますよと
サーリプッタ それはどういう意味でしょうかねと
言ったら あのサーリプッタ尊者もちょっと答えられなくて
ちょっとたもとったというかね
その時お釈迦様は一言葉ヒントを与えたんですね
一言葉ヒントを与えたら
はい わかりましたと言って
ずっと注釈するんですね
注釈していたら お釈迦様
その通りですよと 認めるんですね
それでサーリプッタ尊者あとでもう大変なことになっちゃったんだからね
お釈迦様はいきなりああいう偈私に聞いたら
私には何もわからなくなったんだと
でも お釈迦様のあのすごいヒントで
私にはもういくらでも説明できるんだぞと
ということは これ智慧の第一人者だから
それはヒントで説明できたっていうことなんです
だから その経典でサーリプッタ尊者がもうバカだっていうことを言うために記録しているんではなくて
どれぐらい知識智慧があるんですかという証拠のために記録している経典なんですね
こんなに難しい経典であろうとも
ちょっとヒントさえあればサーリプッタ尊者には解釈できる
他の人にはできないと
だから そういう阿羅漢になってる人
お坊さんたち方にお釈迦様と一緒に生活していたお坊様方にさえも
もう解釈はちょっとごめん
もうごめんというぐらいの難しいところなんですね
ですから 仏教の ABC の知識さえもない大丈夫の文化の中でね
はい スッタニパータやってみるぞっていうのはね
ただ英訳あるんだからといって
英訳見ながら日本語するだけのことですけどね
ですから 当時でとにかく注釈つけたって
注釈はすごい昔つけちゃったんだから
三蔵経を整理する場合はもうできていたんですね
注釈も ですから 注釈も三蔵経の中に入れたんですよ
ということで それぐらい古いんです
今我々が使っている注釈書なんか４世紀で
できた注釈で三蔵経に入ってないんです
別な注釈というふうに別にしているんですね
三蔵経に入れることはできません
それはもうできて終わってるんだから
で まあ随分研究して研究して研究して理解することは不可能なわけではないし
いくつかの注釈書もあるし
いろんな研究者たちがね
一生懸命研究してみるということもあるし
また合点はね 徹底的にパーリ研究した人々がもう最後にそれにぶつけて
それを解釈してみて 大体は驚きますね
やっぱりこれが哲学であって
これこそが仏教だというふうには
まあみんな驚いたりすることは確かですけどね
だからそれで研究論文とかができたりはします
ですから それを最初に読んで仏教をわかって読んだそうと言ってもね
ちょっとわからない可能性はあります
ですから言いたがっているのは
このマニシカロータという言葉の意味なんですけど
ブッダの言葉っていうのは
まあ頭の中でそれは理解しようという努力は必要なんです
その努力すると本当に人が変わっていくんです
ですから ちょっと理解することも努力してみてください
サーデュカ・マニシカロータ
バーシッサーミ これから喋りますと
エーワンバンテーティ コテー ビックゥ バゴウト パッチャーソウスン
はい わかりましたと比丘たちが様様に返事をします
バガワー エータドーチャ
世尊はこのように語ります
セイヤターピ
ビッカヴェー プリソー アッダーナ マッガ パティパンノー ソー パッセイヤ マハンタン ウダカンナワン オーリマン
ティーランサー サンカン サッパティバヤン パーリマン ティーランケーマン アッパティバヤン ナチャスナワー
サンタラーニー ウッタレースーワー パラーワー パーラン ガマナーヤ タッサ エワマッサ アヤンコー マハー ウダカンナウォー
オーリマンチャ ティーランサー サンカン サッパティバヤン パーリマン ティーランケーマン アッパティバヤン ナッティチャナワー
サンタラーニー ウッタレースーワー
アパラーパーラン ガマナー
ヤ ヤンノーナーハン ティナカッタ サーカー パラーサン サнкаッディットワー クッラン バンディットワー タン
クッラン ニッサーヤ ハッテーヒチャ パーデーヒチャ ワーヤマーノー ソッティナー パーラン ウッタレーユンティーというところ
それはもうすごい簡単なところで
まあセイヤターピっていうのは
たとえを言う場合は使う言葉で
まあこんなようなことですよと
プリソー アッダーナ マッガ パティパンノー
人が旅に出る 旅に出た人がいるとします
ソー パッセイヤ マハンタン ウダカンナワン
そうやってずっと道を歩いていくと
マハンタン ウダカンナワン
大きな湖かな 水の流れと訳してます
まあこの水の流れと言えば川なんですけど
川と訳してパーリ語では川には他の言葉がありますけど
大きな水の流れっていうのは注釈書の中だと思いますけど
まあとにかくアンナワっていうのはこの海に使うもう一つの同義語なんですね
ですから 海に使う言葉だから
これは海の話ではないんだからね
陸上の話なんですね ですから
かなりの大きな湖っていうことなんですね
川でも別に悪くはないんですけどね
インドに大きな湖があるかどうかちょっとわかりませんですけど
ものすごい大きな川なんかはありますしね
アンナワットというのは一応湖か海ということで
ですから かなりの大きな湖にぶつかってしまうんですね
それでオリマンティーランサーサンカンサッパティバヤン
オリマンティーラン オリマンというのはこちら側の岸ですね
それは大変こちら側はサーサンカン
これ危険で 大変危険なところでサッパティバヤン恐怖
恐怖 いろいろ恐怖があると
危険は何なのかわかりませんだけど
とにかくもうこちら側が大変
こちらにいたら大変危険ですね
もう恐怖でもいられないんですね
パーリマンティーラン
向こうの岸はね ケーマンサッパティバヤン
大変ケーマンというのは平安で何の恐怖もないんだと
安全で恐怖のない 向こうの岸は安全で恐怖のないところで
それなんですけど だから歩いていた人が湖にぶつかって
もう湖 あまり大きすぎて回って渡るわけにはいきませんし
やっぱり渡らなくちゃいけないんですけども
こちらはいることにもできません
これはすごい危険なところです
それでナチャッサナーワサンターラーニ
ナチャアッサナーワ 船もない
サンターラニ サンターラニナーワ
渡る船もない 渡し船がない
ウッタレイヤ アパラアパランガマナイ
こちらから向こうの岸へ渡っていきたいんだけど
なかなか船がない タッサエーワマッサ
彼がこのように考える
また考えることは全部ずっと同じことを続けていくんですね
この湖のこちら側が大変危険で
でも渡る船もないんでしょうと
そういうふうに彼が考える
それで次にヤンノーナーハン
これは動詞が先に来るんですね
私はこのようにした方がいいと思いますよと言って
することが後で来るんですね
それはパーリの順番なんですね
ヤンノーナーハン ティナカッタサーカーパラサン
ティナというのは草のことで
カッタっていうのは枝ですね
枝の一種ですけど 草と木と書いて木と枝と
それで草やら木やら枝やらね
それからいろいろ葉っぱとかね
そういうもう何でもそこら辺にあるものは
私はサンカディットワ集めて
クンランバンディットワいかだを作るんだと
バンディットっていうのは結ぶという意味なんですね
だからいろんなものを一緒にして結んで
いろいろするを持ってきて
何とかして結んで とにかくいかだを作りましょうと
作った方がいいんじゃないかなと
それでクンランバンディットワタンクンランニッサーエ
そのいかだに支えられてというかね
いかだニッサーヤっていうのはいかだ
支えられてということで
それだけではなくて ハッテーヒチャパーデーヒチャ
両手で両足で ワーヤマーノ
大変努力して 手足で努力して
ソッティナ 無事に パーラン
向こうの岸へ ウッタレイヤ
渡っていきましょうと
行こうと 渡っていこうではないかと
と彼が思いましたと だから彼が思いましたということが先に来るんですね
渡っていった方がいいと
アタ
コーソービッカウェープリソーティナカッタサーカーパラサンサンカディットワクンランバンディットワタンクンランニッサーエハッテーヒチャパーデーヒチャワーヤマーノソッティナアパランウッタレイヤ
それでその人はもう木やら枝やら葉っぱやら集めて集めて
とにかくいかだを結んで作って
それでこの湖を渡る タッサティンナッサパーランガタッサエーワマッサ
そこでティンナッサパーランガタ
ティンナッサというのは渡った人
渡った彼にパーランガタッサ
向こうの岸へ行った彼にこのような考え方が起きます
エーワマッサ エーワンアッサっていうのは
このような考え方が起きますと
バフカーロメーアヤンクッロ
このクッラというものが
このいかだがバフカール
ずいぶん助けになりますと
よく助けてくれたと すごくありがたいことだと
この筏がなかったならばもう渡れませんでしたからね
ですから これはもう大変
この筏方 ものすごいありがたかったもの
ありがたい いわゆるよく助けになったものやと
イマーハン クッラン ニッサーエ ハッテヒチ パーデュヒチ ワーエマーナ スッティナ パーラン ウッティンノ
この筏のおかげで 私は手足で頑張ってやっと無事に渡りましたと
それでヤンヌーナーハン イマン クッラン スィーセー ワーアーローペッタ
ですから 私はこういうふうにした方がいいんだと
この筏をスィーセー アーローペッタ
頭に乗せて カンデーワ ウッチャーレと
あるいは背に肩に乗せてと
ジェーナ カーマン パッキャメイヤン
これから私は行きたいところ
どこでも行くところに
いつでも私がこの筏を頭に乗せて
あるいは背中に乗せて持っていった方がいいんじゃないかなと
なぜならば 大変助けになりましたんだからと
すごいありがたいものでしたからと
その人はこんなことを考えちゃうんですね
タンキン マンニャテ ビックエ アピヌソウ プリソウ エーワンカーリ タスミン クッレ キッチャカーリ アッサーティ
そこでお釈迦様は比丘たちに聞くんですね
タンキン マンニャシ そのことをキン マンニャシ
どのように思いますか？そのことはどのように思いますか
アピヌソウ プリソウ エーワンカーリ
その人がエーワンカーリ
そのようにする いわゆる筏を運ぶ
筏を運ぶということをして
タスミン クッレ キッチャカーリ アッサーティ
その筏にするべきことをしている人ですか
いわゆる本当に感謝している人ですかと
いわゆるお世話になった人に感謝するっていうことは一般的な思考でしょうに
いわゆるお返しするとかね
感謝をするとかね そういうキッチャカーリっていうことはその意味なんですね
するべきことをする 筏について行うべきことを行う者となるでしょうと
本当に筏に対して感謝する人になるんでしょうかと
どうでしょうかね それで比丘たちの答えはね
皆様と違って 昔は比丘たちはよくお釈迦様には答えたり
質問の答え出したり 質問出したりはしたんですけど
ノーヘータン バンテー
そうではないと お釈迦様が説法するときは
相手がもう全然理解しようとしないとね
頭の中で理解しようとしない
努力しないと 対話的になってこないと説法しないんだからね
だから説法成り立たないんだよ
相手の心の中でもちゃんと対話が出てきて
自分にはもう固定概念持っているんだから
それとブッダの言葉っていうのは当然ぶつかるはずなんですよ
ぶつからないと思ったらとんでもないインチキ嘘なんですよ
当然ぶつかるんで ぶつかったものは正直にこういうことはこういうことではないか
こういうふうに理解すればいいんでしょうかとかね
あるいはどのように理解すればいいんでしょう
私の理解が正しい とかね
そうやってものすごくあのダイアログをするんですね
何もしないんだったら
もう何も言わないんですね
ダイアログ何もしなかった人といえば
このアナータピンディカ only だけなんです
アナータピンディカが来たら
お釈迦様は何か説法する
自分で勝手に それ以外
誰にも自分勝手に説法してないんです
イサカ夫人もいましたけど
在家の信者さん二人いたんだけど
偉大なる信者さん二人でイサカス夫人がもういろいろやりとりやっちゃうんです
喧嘩もするんで お釈迦様とお釈迦様に何かお釈迦様はダメですよ
やりませんと もう断れる時もあるし
もうアナンダ only 尊者はそういうふうなもうことをしなかったんですね
もう男性でしたけど やっぱりあのあまりにもお釈迦様のこと心配してね
もう毎日毎日もうみんなに説法してるんだから
もう私はお釈迦様の身の回りの面倒を見て楽にしてあげるんだよと
その上失踪までしてお釈迦様を困らせたらいかんと言って
ただもう身の回りのことを伺って
もう元気ですか？何かね
体の調子はいかがでしょうかとかね
そこら辺を聞いてもう帰ろうとするんで
いつでも で それでお釈迦様のそんじゃこじをつかまって何か説法してあげるんですね
だから彼が彼の頭の中では
このあれは生まれないんですよ
葛藤っていうのはね もう預流果に悟っていましたし
ですからこの概念ぶつかるっていうことはなかったし
ですからお釈迦様おっしゃったことはその通りにもう理解して帰るし
それ以外経典の中で記録してないんです
ほとんどの経典というのは質問に答えるという形式でなってるんですね
で 自分たちの弟子たちがね
いくらか育ててくる場合は
時々お釈迦様がわざと言って自分で質問を出していじるということもあります
わざと自分で質問を出して
もういじってみる 頭をね
そうすると弟子たちがやっぱりそれにまた質問に答えながら答えながら
そこでまた必要な説法をして帰っちゃうしね
自分の息子に説法した時でも
やっぱりいつでも対話形式で
こういうことですよと
こういうことですよというふうに
分かりましたか？と というふうなことで説法するんです
だから一応比丘たちが
まあこれ余計な話なんですけど
答えたんですね そうではないと
それでカタンカーリイチェソウビクウェープリソウタスミンクッレキッチャカーリヤッセ
カタンカーリ どのようにしたならば
ソウプリソウ その人がタスミンクッレ
そのいかだについてキッチャカーリヤッセ
感謝したことになるんでしょうか
といわゆるするべきことを行うべきことをした人になるんでしょうかと
このキッチャカーリっていうのは
直訳すれば行うべきことを行う人という意味なんですけど
それはもうパーリ語では専門用語ではないんですけど
パーリの表現ではキッチャカーリっていうのは感謝する
恩を知るという意味なんです
ですから 親に対する感謝と恩返しあるでしょう
それも親に対するキッチャカーリでしょうし
子供に対しても同じことあるし
それもキッチャカーリであるし
親戚に対して 友人に対して
いろいろ人に対して行うべきことを行いなさいという
この一言葉でまとめているんですね
我々の現代の言葉で言えば
それは感謝でもあるし
親孝行でもあるし もう親にとっても孝行でもあるし
もういろいろ言葉たくさんありますけどね
やっぱりするべきことをしなさいという意味で
全部一言葉にまとめているんです
そこでどのようにすればいいんでしょうかと聞くんですね
イデビクエタッサプルサッセティンナッサパーランガタッセエワマッセ
渡ったその人にこのように考え方生まれると
バフカーロメアヤンクッロム
このいかだがすごい助けになりましたよと
このいかだによって私はよく無事に渡りましたと
ヤンノーナハンイマンクッラン
タレーワウッサーデットワ
ウダケーワウップラーペットワ
イエーナカーマンパックマヘヤン
ですから私はヤンノーナハン
こんなことをした方がいいんじゃないかなと
イマンクッラン タレーワウッサーデットワ
このいかだを引っ張って
もうタレーっていうのはこの岸の方で
そこら辺でちょっと引っ張って
そのまま置いておく あるいはウダケーワウップラーペットワ
でないと水の中に蹴っ飛ばしちゃって
自分が一応陸に行って
そのままそれも引っ張ってそこら辺に置いておくか
あるいは水の中にも蹴っ飛ばして流しちゃうとか
イエーナカーマンパックマヘヤン
私は好きなところに行くんだぞと
いわゆるいかだを捨てるんですね
何の欲しがることも惜しむこともなく
それがやるべきことをやったことなんです
なすべきことをやったことなんですね
エワメワコビクウェー
クンループもマヤダンモデーシと
このように私はいかだに例えて法を語ってますよと
説法しているんだよと
ニッタルナッタイ 渡れよと
ノーガハナッタイ 運ぶなよと
アホだと 運ぶ人は ありがたい説法
ありがたい説法と思って勉強して
もうただ暗記して運ぶだけで
もうアホだけなんですね
それはもう渡れと これは使って
道具として使って クンループマンウォービッケウェーアージャナンテーヒダンマンピウォーパハータンバ
このクンループマンといういかだの例えを知っている人がダンマンピウォーパハータンバ
いかだの例えを知っている人だったらダンマさえも法さえも真理さえもパハータンバ捨てるべきですよと
パゲーはアダンマ 真理でないものについてはもう話にならんと
だからそれはできるかということなら
世の中にあるすべては妄想
概念で 欲で 感情で 貪瞋痴で作り出している哲学
思想というのはすべてそういうものなんですよ
金が高い高価なものや
もうダイヤが高価なものやということさえも
すべて人間が欲で作った考え方なんですね
我々はそういう思考からなかなか抜けられない
でも仏教はわかると そんなものは全部無常で何の意味もないとわかるはずなんですね
わかったんだからって仏教がありがたいということもダメですよと
それも捨てなさいと 世の中の思想に対してはもう話にならんと
そうやって絶対的にすべて捨てる道を教えているんですね
一切を捨てる道を教えているんです
それからお釈迦様がまた説法を始めるんですね
捨てる説法 チャイマーニビッケウェーディッティッターナーニ
ディッティっていうのは見だから
これはもう意見のことで
もうどうせ見という言葉
仏教使う場合は間違ってる意見という意味なんですね
何か固定概念にしがみすぎていること場合は
見というディッティということを使っても
パーリ語のディッティっていうのは間違ってる意見と
これははっきりしているんです
日本語の見ではそんなことはっきりしませんだけど
パーリ仏典の中だったら
でもインドの普通の言葉にしたってもディッティという
どうでしょうかね 他の言語でどうかちょっと今ちょっと不安になりましたけどもね
ディッティはどのように他の言語で使っているんでしょうか？というなかなか思い出せない
実例とか 一応パーリについてははっきりしています
ディッティという言葉が出たらもう邪見
ディッティッターナーニというのはやっぱりこの何に支えられて
何を根拠にして 何を土台にして
何を基本ベースにして見が邪見が成り立ったかっていうところなんですね
だからこの場合は この世の中にある邪見をね
全部もうまとめてインデックスしてお釈迦様が喋ろうとしているわけじゃないんです
世の中の邪見というのは限りなくあるんだから
それで宗教的な邪見のみ
当時インドでは もういくつかたくさんありましたけど
それもお釈迦様がお釈迦様の思想で分析して六十二にしているんですね
その場合ははっきりと六十二種類の宗教がインドにありましたよと注釈書で書いてますけど
研究してみると いろんな西洋の研究者たちがね
これは仏教の人々の勝手な解釈で
そんなものはなかったんだとかねと言ってるし
まあそういうのは一重ありますけど
で またさらに研究して
やっぱりまあ調べれば見つかるんだぞと言って
あるすごい恐ろしい能力のある学者が全部調べちゃったんですね
その人が早く死んじゃったんだけど
彼の能力にはもう世界で誰にも比べられないものすごい能力
もう西洋哲学の権威で
それでも言語というのはもうどこまで知ってるかという
もう怖いほどもうインド言語っていうのは全部知っていて
それを徹底的に だから彼の論文はだいたい普通の人やろうとすれば
まあだいたい四十年ぐらいはかかるかもしれませんと
で これをもうさっさと淡々ともう三年で研究してまとめちゃったんです
すごい大きな本ですけどね
あれは訳してもわからないと思いますけどね
で 論文としては読みにくいかもしれませんだけど
まあ本当に読む人が学者であるならば
この項目ごとに読むと
もう驚くほどの知恵が出て
もう知識が出てくる本なんですね
項目ごとだから 全てのこの段落に番号を振っているんです
だからまあ私は個人的な意見なんですけど
あれほど知恵の倉庫っていうのはないんですよ
いろんな研究論文を読んだこと
膨大な研究もありますけどね
グループでもかなり時間かけてね
大きいだけでいいっていうわけでもないしね
それからこの やっぱりそれを理解するためには
もう西洋ウェスタンフィロソフィーというものにはものすごい馴染みがないと読めないと思いますけどね
タイトルは初期仏教の認識論というタイトルなんですけどね
認識論になるな Theory
of Knowledge
知識のTheoryというね
いわゆるエピステモロジーという哲学の分野に入っている本なんですけど
私は昔は聖書のごとく
あの本はいつでもまあそばに置いておくという
この本をもう買えなかった学生の時代では
まあ図書館の本はもうむちゃくちゃもうボロボロになってたっていう
もうあまりに読みすぎて
それからはやっぱりいつでもまあ枕元にあったんですね
日本に来るとはまあ置いてきたんだけどね
まあそれは基本的なことを理解するために
その人が人一つ哲学思考だからね
一つ一つ調べて調べて
どこかに似ているところ見つかるんですね
インド思想の中で まあこういうことではないかと言っているのと
だからとにかく宗教哲学としては六十二というふうには分けてあって
それはお釈迦様がまあ全部邪見だよと言ってますし
ですから この これからお釈迦様がこの人の邪見を裁こうとするんではなくて
なぜ邪見が生まれるんでしょうかと
なぜ人がもう邪見ではなくて
なぜそんな意見出すんでしょうかと
例えばすべては絶対的な神が最初
だから最初は神がいて
すべては絶対的な神が作ったっていうことは意見でしょ？見でしょ
だからそれがそんな神がいないぞとかね
というふうな喧嘩に突くんではなくて
なぜそういうふうな意見ができるんでしょうか
そこら辺を考えるんですね
意見を置いておくんです
それで置いておいて なぜそんな意見が出すんでしょうかと
その根拠を調べるんですね
そういう根拠がチャ 六つあります
邪見が出てくる根拠っていうのは六つあります
まあそれからこれは説法だからね
ずっと因縁とこの説法のスタイルで流れていくんですけど
そんな長く読まなくても
ちゃんと項目だけ書いて説明すれば
まあ講義みたいになりますけど
イデ
ビッケー アスートワ プトゥッジャノ アリアーナン アダッサアヴィ アリアダンマッサ アコヴィドゥ アリアダ
ンミ アヴィニート サップリサーナン アダッサアヴィ サップリサダンマッサ アコヴィドゥ サップリサダンミ アヴィニートというところ
それはいつでも決まり文句で出てくること
教育のない人って意味なんですよ
まとめて言えば 教育のない人
出来が悪い人というね
いわゆるちゃんと人間っていうのは思考をちゃんと洗練して置いておかないとね
きちんとした教育を受けて
きちんとした思想を持って
分類性をちゃんと持って育てなくちゃいけないんですね
仏教はいつでもインテリ主義だから
一応主義で言えば 信仰すぎとか
そんなもうもうみっともない主義ではないんですね
拝みすぎとかね まあ拝み屋でもないし
もう祈り世界でもないし
賛美歌の世界でもないし
もう徹底的にインテリですね
だからまあ インテリジェンスということと宗教っていうのはもう現代世界では噛み合わないんですよ
宗教はインテリジェンスの反対だと勘違いしているんですね
勘違いじゃない それは確かに世の中にある宗教はインテリジェンスを否定して作っているものだから
信仰に基づいて語っているんだから
だから宗教家が偉そうに言うのは
これは科学では説明できませんぞと威張るんですよ
だから 人間の理屈 論理に当てはめないことを言って
それが宗教だと ただ威張っただけで威張れるものじゃないんです
人間には霊魂というものがあると
そんなもう現代科学者たちがまるっきりそんなことは分かってないんだぞと
それでいいんですか？そんな言葉言って
霊魂があるというなれば
こういうわけで こういうわけで
こういうわけで霊魂があるんではないかと
こういうことで 科学者にはそれは見いだせないんだぞというのはインテリ的な言い方であって
だから霊魂があるんだよという自由はありますよ
人にはもう霊魂がありますよという
これは哲学的な結論だから
それはいいんですけど
言うのは 問題はなぜその結論に至ったかと
その思考体系 この思考の流れ
論理構成 証拠というものは出して故にあるんだぞというふうに言わなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それはないんです 言いたい放題ことを言う
それで霊魂があるんだよと
霊魂は光でありますよとか
何でも言うでしょうね
それだったら 証拠は要らんと
証拠は要らんと言ったら何でも言うんですね
だからこの宗教の その現代わかりやすい宗教テキストといえばそれだから読んで理解すればいいのに
インテリ的じゃないかと
でもそれは皆様にばれるかどうか分かりませんだけどね
大体ちょっとした理解能力あればすぐもうもうダラダラとこれはわかると思いますけどね
だから聖書にしたっても
他のそんな聖典にしたっても証明出さないんですね
でも証明出す必要が人間にあるんだということはいくらかは分かっています
なぜキリスト教で奇跡物語があるかというと
それのためなんですね
イエス様が神の子であるということを証明したくて
もう生き返ったんだとかね
そこでこの病気の人を治したんだとかね
湖上を歩いたんだとかね
そういうなんとかなんとか奇跡をリストして
それは人間にはできないでしょうと
この人だけできましたよと
故に神の子ですよと それはやっぱり神の子であるということは
証拠を出せるために奇跡を使っているんですね
だから奇跡に頼ったということ自体はまま
また別な知識的に論じるとあまりにも弱すぎなんですね
奇跡自体が本物かないかっていうことは
我々に出している証拠だから
我々はそれを調べる権利があるんですよ
確かに奇跡でしたと それはできませんだからね
それは誰かさんの記録だからね
いくらでも嘘を書けるでしょうに
ですから もう証拠には本当はならないんですね
でも聖書はそれなりには頑張ってはいますけどね
それはまあ証拠ですよということでね
まあ古いものだからね
今更今になってもね 調べることもできないしね
でもブッダの教えの場合は
そういうもう昔の話だから
今証拠できませんという
例えば聖書の場合は 本当にイエス様が殺されてからね
日目で復活しましたかと
それは嘘ではないかという疑問が今起きたら
どうやって調べればいいんですかね
だからイエス様が神の子であったということは
復活したことでもう最終もう何て言いますか
もう決まりですよそれで
それがもう決定的な証拠で
その なのに その決定的な証拠は今調べることはできないんですね
証拠を出しているのは神の子と知らない我々凡夫のためなんですよ
残念なことに それはもう無理ですね
だからその弱みというかね
あります ではブッダの教えはどうですかと
ブッダの教えは今古いんだから
二千五百年も経ってるんだから
もう証拠は調べられませんと言えますかね
その差を考えてほしいんです
一つも今の時代で 今の瞬間で証拠を出せないものというのは一つもないんです
自分で調べないんだと
ブッダが言ったことは本当かないかと
調べられますよ だって心のこと言ってるんだから
煩悩のこと言ってるんだから
煩悩から苦しみが生まれてくるんだ
執着から並ならぬ苦しみが生まれてくるのは
執着ある限りはこの苦しみは続けるんだぞと
証拠ない？ちょっと調べたらいくらでも証拠あるでしょうに
今でも将来でも それがインテリ中のインテリ的な教えなんですね
証拠ないものは何もないっていうところがね
ですから このブッダの教えは徹底的にインテリ的であるっていうことを言うために
この今言ってるこの決まり文句をよくパーリ聖典では出てくるんですね
ですから 仏教を実践することをね
勉強することは 日本では恥ずかしいことだと思ってますけどね
そう思うこと自体も自分の顔に泥を塗るぐらいの恥ずかしいことと私は逆に思ってます
なぜならば もう仏教なんかはもうもうインチキくさくてね
恥ずかしいやと 隠れては勉強しますけども
公ではやりませんと言って
公で何やって何を勉強していますかね
神の言葉とか 霊の言葉とか
ですから まあまるっきりこの論理的でないものはものすごく胸を張ってやっていて
超能力の話とか UFO
の話とか それが恥ずかしいと私は思いますけどね
そこで新興宗教みたいなものができちゃうと
もう全くひとかけらも知恵の知識のないものができたりとか
それぐらいそれは恥じるべきだと思いますよ
宗教は全然認めないと言ったら
それはもういいんで 別にもう現代的でね
逆ですからね 認めないと言いながら一番たくさん持っている
まあそういうことで 仏教はすごい厳密にインテリ的な教えなんです
それはどうやって説明するかというと
アッスータワプトゥッジャナ
アッスータワっていうのは勉強してないという意味なんですね
スッタっていうのは聞くという意味で
だからたくさん聞いたっていうことは
もう大量に勉強している人という意味
アッスータワっていうのは無学ですね
プトゥッジャナっていうのは凡夫一般の人
アリアーナンアダッサーヴィ
アリアっていうのは聖者という意味で
この場合はものすごい立派な人っていう意味でね
いわゆるインテリということでいいんでしょう
訳はね そういうすごい知識の知恵のある人はアダッサーヴィ
見たことがない アリエダンマッサアコウィド
そうやって賢者の教えについて下手
アコウィドっていうのはコウィド上手っていうことで
アコウィドっていうのはものすごいもう下手
もうもうもうダメですね
やっぱり いわゆるチンプンカンプンで
賢者の教えについてはもうチンプンカンプンで
全く全く理解できない状態で
アリエダンメアヴィニート
ヴィニータっていうのはディシプリンという育てることなんですね
学校に行って いろんな専門学校に行って
我々はもう ディシプリンというものをね
教育訓練を受けちゃうんですね
それはヴィニータっていうんですね
アリアダンメ 賢者の教えについてはディシプリン教育は受けてない
サップリサーナンアダッサービ
サップリサっていうのはすごいまあ善人ですね
サップリサっていうのは善人
素晴らしい人っていうことで SAT
がプリサにつくんです T
は消えちゃってPになるんです
サっていうのは真理っていうことですけどね
意味 意義 まあ本物って意味なんでサっていうのはね
ヒンドゥー教ではアートマンに魂に使う言葉なんですね
だからヒンドゥー教におけるヒンドゥー教でウパニシャッドによると
全てのものはマーヤーで幻覚であって
我のみ本物なんですね
それは消えないもの これは現象ですから消えちゃうんですね
ですからサというんですね SAT
サット サンスクリット語でSATサットというのは真理がっていう意味で
だからお釈迦様それは一般的な言語として使ってますね
だから本物 本当の意味
真理って意味なんですね
だから真理の人って意味なんですね
サップリサっていうのは
サンスクリット語で言う場合はサップリサと読みます
プルシャですね サットプルシャ
それはパーリ語になるとサップリサになります T
はPになるんです ですからそれは真理の人っていう意味だけではなくて
善人という意味でも使ってます
同じ言葉 善人の教えにはまあ教えを受けてない
出会ったこともないし
下手でしょうし 訓練も受けてないし
善人の教えに いわゆるある人がものすごい素晴らしい人に会ったことがない
そういう思想教育も受けたこともない人がこう思うんですよ
ルーパン まずルーパについて
ルーパっていうのは物質的なものなんですね
我々の体で認識できるものはほとんどルーパなんですよ
耳で取れる情報もルーパであって
目で取れる情報もルーパであって
物質であって 鼻で取れる情報も物質でありますね
口で取る情報も物質でありますね
体で触れる情報も全て物質なんですね
体に物質が触れて 我々はあるということを感じるんですね
だから物質で言っても流れですけどね
我々は個体として これがテープレコーダー
個体テープレコーダーが個体としてあるんだよと言っても
目で情報を取って 体で情報を取って言うだけのことなんですね
だから体に触れる情報っていうのは
硬さとか温度でふたしかないし
目で触れるのは光しかないしね
それで構成するんですよ
テープレコーダーという物体を
だから実際にテープレコーダーという物体があるかっていうことはわからないことなんです
これは頭で作る構成なんですね
だから我々は頭で構成されちゃって
現象観になっちゃって
実際の世界は 宇宙もあるんだぞと思ってるんですね
我々に入る情報はそういう個体的な情報ではなくて
ずっと流れる情報なんですね
もうずっと変化して変化生滅する情報なんですね
ですから 宇宙から出てくる光の情報はずっと変化生滅している情報だから
故に宇宙も変化生滅しているものだよという仮定はできます
推測は だから外の世界について
我々はそういうチャネルとしてしか知らないんですね
それ自分の体もありますね
それも一つの物質ですね
物体ですね 体も 体物体だと
じゃあテープレコーダーは物体だと頭で幻想化するとしたならばね
じゃあ体は自分でわかってるんだから幻想化する必要ないでしょうと
体も幻想化する 頭の中で目で見られる故に目があると
耳で聞こえる故に耳があると
体でいろんなことを感じる
いろんなことはないんだけど
痛みとかね 寒いとかしか感じませんよ
それで故に体があると
と頭の中で幻想ですね
幻覚を作り出すんですね
それで体があると我々はもうそこが真理だと思ってしまう
だからそこ今説明したところは誰にもわからないんですね
みんな一発でテープレコーダーあるんじゃないかと
テープレコーダーがあるんだよと
これこれですよと 録ることもできますよと言うんであって
それはもうもう幻想の世界で喋ってるんですね
なぜそんな幻想が来るかって
そこら辺は研究しないんですね
ですから いきなりルーパが存在するんですよ
この勉強していない無学の人々にとっては
真の先生に出会ったことは一生ない人々にとってはね
体があるんだと それで彼が「エータンママ」
その体について 「エータン」
これが「ママ」 私ですと
エータンママという場合はこのどんなケースですか？って 2番目
まあ一応これノミネティブではなくてニュートラルで
で これが私ですよと思う
この体が私ですよと 「
エソーハマス」ね 「エソー」という場合はこのマスキュリンジェンダーでノミネティブケース使ってますね
で これがいわゆるこのルーパが「アハンアスミ」 「
アハン」私は 私はルーパですよと思う
そこはこんなすっごい気に細かい思考なんです
日本訳しちゃうともう潜伏しちゃう
それは日本語ではもうちょっと直訳できないですけどね
日本語で直訳できないと言ったっても
人間の思考はみんな同じなんです
物事の認識過程はね  3番目「エソーメアッタ」
これが私の我であると
魂 霊魂であると 「サマヌパッサティ」もう考え決めちゃうんですね 「
サマヌパッサティ」っていうのは
まあそういうふうな理解して
その立場でいるんだという
ですから 何の勉強をしてない人々にとっては
もういとも簡単に体があるんだということを思ってしまっちゃうんですね
それは頭の中の一つの幻想ですね
合成するんですね 情報
合成してある幻想 イメージを作っちゃうんですね
そのイメージがもうイメージで理解するんですよ
イメージがないと理解できない
だから我々の認識っていうのは全てイメージの並べなんですね
全てイメージ 例えば目を開けて何か見ると見えないはずなんです
見ても だってずーっと光の情報がずーっと流れているだけでしょうに
だから視覚が生まれるだけ
視覚 視覚だけで それは何なのかということは成り立たないんだ
何でもないんです でもそのずっと出てくるこの視覚の情報はまとめて何かイメージを作る
それで木だ 建物だ 窓だとかカーテンだとか
我々はそれで概念もつけて概念作っちゃうんですね
一応 それから言葉もつける
まず概念作って それから言葉つけます
ですから まず情報が入る
視覚が生まれる それは万人に同じ
10人が並んで座って目を開けたら 10
人にも同じ情報入るんです
目に 視覚はですから万人に同じなんですよ
光に対する反応だから視覚は
それで視覚のデータをもう消えちゃったんですけど
もう消えたんだけど もうあるところまで
まあここら辺までというふうにいくらか取って
頭の中で合成しますね
それでイメージを作るんです
イメージを作るためには
合成する場合は そのその人が他のデータ
いろいろ過去のデータとか使うんですね
一番気をつけてほしいのは
この感情判断とかね 過去の感情
過去の判断データも取り入れて
それで何かイメージを作っちゃうんです
この作っちゃイメージは全くその人に種類です
だから 目を開けて人が同じものを見ることはありえないんです
入った情報は万人に同じなんです
でも視覚は種類なんです
だから評価も種類であって
好き嫌いも全部それぞれバラバラ
そこで個体という幻覚が出てくるんですね
私は別人だよと それで私がいるんだよという
この仮定ですよ 推測ですね
そういう推測はずっと出てくるんですね
なぜその推測出てくるかって
このプロセスをわかってないんだから
そこで私がいるんだよと
私の体も体があるんだよということまでいく
言って さらにいい加減に仮定する
これが私のものだよと
これが私というものだよと
その考え方を作るためには
かなり妄想しないとできないものなんですね
だから 私が思う故に私がいるということは
もう激しい妄想の結果なんですね
瞬間の思考じゃないんです
瞬間の思考だったら 一般の人だったら
例えば子供だったら木があるんだ
鳥が飛んできたんだ それで終わっちゃうでしょうね
故に私に魂があるんだ
私に魂があるんだと思わないんですよ
だから子供の方がマシなんですよ
もう鳥が飛んだということは幻想なんですけど
幻覚なんですけど 故に私がいるんだ
これが私の魂だまではいかないんですね
それで大人になってくれば
さらに頭が脳細胞がもう壊れてしまって
故に私がいるんだと それが私の魂だと言うんですね
証拠ないんですよ あんまりにもいい加減な考え方なんです
なのに 世の中で魂があるんだということにどれぐらい哲学あるんですか？という中で
だから仏教から見れば
まあまあゴミとも言えないほどのゴミなんで
ゴミでも時々役に立ちますけど
ゴミから出たゴミなんですよ
このゴミリサイクルする時でもゴミからゴミ出るでしょ
それはもう全くもう何の役にも立たない
だから我っていうのは
そうやってこのゴミから出たゴミなんですね
それで三段階で私のもの
私ですということと 私の我ですと
私のものですよという場合は
もう一般的な誰にでも思う
そのステップはね 人類は誰でも私のという思考が生まれてくる
その邪見がね 体が私のものやと
この場合 ルーパってのは自分の体のことなんですね
この体が私のものやということは
もう全ての人間に生まれる邪見なんです
もうちょっと欲が強い人がこれが私ですと
ちょっときついんですね
執着が で そういう風になりますね
もっとアホな人がこれが私の我ですよと
霊魂 魂ですよと思っちゃうんですね
それはどういうことかというと
その人がいろんな宗教家かもしれません
魂を探求した人かもしれません
神が一人のために頑張っている人かもしれません
あるいはいろんなウパニシャッドの仙人たちに出会って
魂についてもういろいろ教えられて教えられて教えられて
頭はもう意見いっぱいで
でも魂が何なのかってまだ発見せていない
それでつなげちゃう あ
我っていうのは これが
この色が この体が その先生がおっしゃっている我ですよと
だから番目はもう宗教哲学者が作る邪見幻想なんです
それはもうすごい無知の最もどん底なんですよ
私のものやと言ったところは
もう誰にでも生まれる無知であって
これはもうどんな人にでも生まれるんですね
それは仏教の修行で執着を捨てるということを捨てることはできます
すごい哲学的に見えるところは
より頭がおかしい人が作るものなんです
よりたくさん余計なことを考えて作るものなんですね
西洋でも同じことなんですね
精霊というものがあるんだと
霊魂というものがあるんだと
神がこの物質に吹き込んだものがあるんだと
言うんだけど それは何なのかとわからないんですね
それで西洋でもこの体
それが霊魂 精霊やと思う
だから火葬しないんです
埋葬するんです で キリスト教の方はどんどん科学発展したんだから
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃって
理屈つける人もあるんだからいるんだからね
魂は不滅であるならば
火葬したことでも燃えるわけじゃないんだと
と理屈つけちゃって もう火葬する場合もあります
イスラム教はまだまだ原始宗教で絶対火葬しません
火葬しちゃうともう終わりと
魂が燃えてしまいますよと
ということは 結局は体が魂やと思ってるんですね
燃やしたって体から燃やすだけですからね
なんでイスラム教で泥棒したらもう手を切断したりしますかというと
その人には天国にまで憎しみを持っていくためなんですね
イスラムの人でもイスラムでない人でも
泥棒なんかしたら そこ乗ったらもう手を切っちゃうという
手を切っちゃって その人は死んでからね
天国に行っても手がないんです
だからやった悪いことの罰が天国は永遠でしょ
永遠で受け取らなくちゃいけないという脅しでもあるし
これものすごい脅しですよ
人々にとってはね あれほど脅しているのに
平気で人殺したり 泥棒したり
不倫したりとかね やること
仏教は罪を犯したら その分を償いをしたらもうきれいさっぱりになるんだよという話ですけど
あまり脅してないんですよ
だから脅されてない仏教の人々は一生懸命真面目に罪を犯さないように頑張ってはいます
罪を犯しますよ 犯しますけど
そんなに平気で犯してるわけじゃないんですね
ですから そこら辺でこの体が魂やと思うことが嘘じゃないんです
世の中で確実にそうある
それから人々 この我論を持ってる人々と喋ると
よく喋ってみると 体が魂で取ってるんではないかということはもうわかるんです
で 番目に行きます 番目はヴェーダナー
このヴェーダナーは魂と取ったところはまあ少々進んでいるところなんです
ヴェーダナーっていうのは体で感じることなんですね
だから目で耳で鼻で口で体で感じてるんですよ
だから感じてるんだから
やっぱりそれが私ですよと
例えば手とか足とかね
完全麻痺した時は私という実感が出てこないんですね
あることを知らないんですよ
もう時々医者がね 外科手術する場合は
治療する場合は外科的にエステツケちゃうでしょ？ローカル
各部分だけにね 麻酔かけるでしょうに
もし手に何かしなくちゃいけない場合は
手に麻酔をかけたところで
患者さんが手があることわからなくなっちゃうんですね
医者がもう触ってみてどうですか
感じますか？とかね 言ったら感じないと答えが出てくる
それからそれだけでは足りませんだから本当に本人に聞かないで
ちょっといじったり いろんなことしてみるんですね
それ本人が反応しません
口で聞いたら感じれませんよと言っても
もしかすると感じてる可能性あります
だからさらにちょっといじってみるんでいたら
もう全然反応が出てこない
リフレックスという自動的に反応するところそれで何のことなくメスを入れちゃう
ですから この感覚がないとあるということもないんですからね
ですから 私という実感が感覚から出てくるんですね
それでそれをわからないで
理解しないで この感覚に対して
これが私のもの これが私です
これが私の我ですと と思いますね
そのそれが私ですよということは
誰でもやってます 例えば
私が人の足に殴ったら
人がこの人私を殴ったんだよと言うんですよ
平気で その人を殴ったわけじゃないんですよね
足を殴ったんだけど ですから
我々それを日常使ってます
例えば 自分の左手の指が何か病気になったりしますね
平気でこの頃私は病気ですよと言っちゃうでしょうに
指ですかね 私っていうのは
やっぱりその感覚なんですね
その感覚でそれが私ですよというのは
ごく一般的な人間の妄想概念なんですね
それでもっと頭の悪い人は感覚をまとめてそれが私ですよと思っちゃうんですね
だから その 2つは宗教があってもなくても誰でも陥る邪見なんですね
それは簡単に瞑想で直すことはできますね
それが私かと分析能力で見ればそうでなくなっちゃうんですね
指が私ではないと と決めたところで
次に出てくる邪見が いいえ
指が私のものやと 2番目の邪見に入っちゃうんですね
このセットはこちら出てこないんですけどね
それでさらに分析してみるんですね
指が私のもので 私は別とにいるんだ
足も私のもので 私は別とにいるんだと
胴体も私の胴体で 私は別とにいる
私はどこにあるんでしょうかと見れば
ただ合成して この足と指と胴体に頭に合成して私だよと言ってるだけでしょうと
単なる頭の妄想概念でしょうとわかりますね
それから 我論はもっと簡単に取り除くことはできます
なぜならば それは一番頭の悪い人が作るんだから
魂が霊魂があるんだということ
で 感覚で見て それ見られるでしょ
それが魂やと言ったら
ずっと見られるもの変わるでしょうに
1 分間どれぐらいのものを見られるんですかね
見る見るたびに感覚が変わるでしょうに
だからそんなもうまるっきり変わるんだから
これは我見あらずと すごい簡単にそれはもう解読することはできます
難しいのは私のということなんです
それはみんなに出てくるものです
感覚はそういうふうに取っちゃいますね
2番目にはサンカーリ
サンカーラが業 サンカーラっていうのは
行っていうのは衝動的なエネルギーなんですね
大体怒りも憎しみも欲も大体サンカーラに入っちゃうんですね
感情 大体感情ですね 人間には感情っていうものがあるんじゃないかと
好き嫌いっていうものあるんでしょうと
これどうにもならんでしょうと
好き嫌い変わるわけじゃないでしょうと
そうやって我々は怒り
憎しみ 嫉妬 欲 それから他のもう愛することやら慈しみやらいろいろ善的な感情も不善的な感情もどちらでもいいんですけど
感情的なものって全部サンカーラにしていくんで
それで我々は衝動を起こしちゃうんですね
だからサンカーラって言うんですね
例えば欲しい欲しいという気持ち
感情が出たら それで衝動を起こしちゃうんですね
起きて行動しちゃうんですね
だから行動するためのエネルギー資源です
サンカーラの意味はポテンシャルって意味ですからね
それで感覚ではなくて
どうしても心の中にある好き嫌い
あの人のこと この人のことだったら嫌いとかね
そうやって衝動を起こすエネルギー資源全てサンカーラといって
大体心性のアビダンマで言ってるところ
次はサンニャーが出てきてますね
サンニャーっていうのは単純な認識機能ですね
いわゆる思い出す時とは我々サンニャー使っちゃうんですね
サンニャーっていうのは
仏教の定義っていうのは
ちょっとした目印 しるしってぐらいのもので
ものを見ると何かちょっとひと Fitta サインが心に残っちゃうんですね
それで再確認できるようになるんですね
だから再確認機能してくれるのはサンニャーなんですね
いわゆるこれは建物だとかね
例えばどんなものでも一回見たら
それからその人に同じものを二回目見せる
二回見せると その人それはもうわかるでしょ
確認しちゃう あれですと
言葉なかったらあれですと
なんであれですという気持ちが出てくるんですかね
前一回目見た時のインプレッションですね
サンニャーですね だからそれがなくなっちゃうと
我々は覚えられません
思い出せません あんた誰？と聞くのはもうサンニャーが機能しないんですよ
私は人の名前を覚えられないのも同じことなんです
名前聞いてもサンニャーが生まれてこないんですね
ですから 何回何回何回何回何回聞いて
微かに生まれる すぐ消えちゃいますからね
微かなサンニャーが 何回何回も聞いちゃうと
同じサンニャーがリピートされますから
一応覚えられるということになるんですね
ですから 世の中で頭いいっていうのは記憶力ですよ
大体はね それはサンニャーの力なんですね
記憶力っていうのはサンニャーの力
思い出せます だから勉強することっていうのは大したことない
いろんなサンニャーがいっぱい溜まって
それは適当に思い出せる
それでよく勉強した人と言うんですね
いっぱいいっぱいいっぱい勉強しても
一つ思い出せなかったら
我々は勉強したとは言えないんですね
だから世の中で勉強しました
本読みましたということは
もう思い出せるというぐらいのことです
だからそれは人には向き不向きあります
私には人の名前を思い出せるということは不向きと勝手に言ってますけど
本当はもうやりたくないということなんですけどね
もうやりたければできないわけじゃないんだけどね
でも他のことはもう大体一発で言えます
この間 私は通訳した長老の話は
今チャレンジしても 私は初めから終わりまでその通りに言えます
覚えているんです だからそこは一発で覚え
これは要りません 私には
それにはサンニャーがちゃんと作るんですよ
でも名前聞いたらわかるんです
だからミャンマーから来るお坊さんたちのミャンマーの名前はありますけど
それは先生わかってない
それで強引にパーリ語の名前聞いて
ミャンマーのパーリだからあるいはパーリじゃないんだから
それを私は普通のパーリ語に入れ替えて
それで名前を普通のパーリ語に入れた瞬間に名前は覚えています
あのお坊さんはニャーニッサラという名前だから
それは普通のパーリ語だったら
それは覚えられます それはパーリ語を知ってるんだから
すぐサンニャーが出てきます
とにかくサンニャーというのはそんなもんで
勉強の世界で思い記憶力の世界なんですね
ですから たくさん勉強した人のサンニャーのサンニャーパイですね
サンニャーパイがすごい大きいんですね
勉強してない人のサンニャー体が少ない
でも誰にでもサンニャーが確実にある
なくてはならない ならないっていうことはありえないんですよ
ないともう もうそれでも死んだことですからね
だから言葉あってもなくても
我々はあれこれとか思い出したりしますからね
そこでこのサンニャー思い出す
いろいろ工夫すると さらに記憶力っていうのはすごく鋭くなりますね
だからこのいろいろ工夫する
例えば漢字を覚えるためにいろいろ工夫するでしょうに
あれはサンニャーいじってるんですね
だから教育方法とかね
というのはもうサンニャーの管理方法なんですね
それでサンニャーが私ではないこと
だからそれもよくみんなにあること
いろんなことを勉強しちゃうと
知らないうちにそれが自分になるんですね
私は医者ですけどとかね
私は弁護士ですけどとかね
平気で言うでしょうに
も 私は弁護士です いわゆるサンニャーが私ですと一番目ですよ
エース・オブ・スパッズ
あんたはどなたでしょうか？私は弁護士ですけど
それで自分のサンニャーが自分だと出すんですよ
それで瞑想する時でも
悟りにはかなり邪魔になるんですね
私はもう決まり切って人の牌だけすくっていく風にしゃべるでしょうに
人の考え方 話 全然当てにしない
もうよっぽどのわけがないと認めないというね
いろいろもうからくりやってますけどね
それでみんなすごくもうカッとなったり
怒ったり もう二度と来ないとかになったりするんだけど
私はまあニコッと笑っちゃいますけど
もう何にそんなに怒って
自分のサンニャーにちょっと気づいたんだからと
それサンニャー壊すんだから
すべてことごとく仏教ではね
ありがたい弁護士様いらっしゃいましたからといって説法は控えるということはありえないんです
たとえ弁護士であろうが医者であろうが大体これはもう仏教ではバカで扱わないと
だから仏教の思想っていうのは
人間の思想とは全くもう全くもう出世間です
とにかく人間っていうのは
自分のサンニャーを私のもの
あるいは私ですとと思ってます
それでもっと頭が悪い人が
それが私の我ですと思っちゃうんですね
例えばヨーロッパの世界にしても
ただみんな世の中でね
この砂漠の中で殺し合いばっかりやって生きていた人々でしょうしね
安らぎっていうのを味わったことがない
水なんかは宝物で 人でも見たらもうもうもうもう殺して食べちゃうぐらいのね
それですごく自分の生き方っていうのは不安で感じちゃう
だから一日生きていられたってもありがたくてたまらない
そういうことで役が回されてるんだということでね
まあ神を想定するんです
それでその文化的な神で戦い
悪い人は殺す で 神が来る前兆として疫病でしょ
聖書を読んでみてください
神が来るんだという前兆として出てくるのは疫病
災い 何でしょうかね 神がもう現れるんだと思ったら
世の中いきなり明るくなって豊かになって
人間がもう憎しみ苦しみをやめて
今までの敵同士の人々もすごい仲良くして
それがもうそろそろ神が現れる前兆やと言った方が
愛の神にふさわしいんですけど
でも残念ながら 私が読んでいるところではね
もう災いは前兆になっちゃうんですね
洪水 疫病 戦争っていうことになっちゃうんですね
ですから それは私は別に
それは文化ですよ やっぱりそういう文化でね
生まれたんだから そういう思考しかできませんね
だから神が来たっていうことは
自分が勝ってあの敵たちをみんな潰しちゃうっていうことで
だから神がそろそろ来ると
敵の人々はみんな疫病でもう崩れて壊れて死にかけてよ
それで ほら ざまあみろと
我々の神が我々を救ってくれるんだっていう単純なね
思考なんですね だから
そういうふうに考えることも結局サンニャーでしょうね
それで現代このイエホワの証人たちとかね
もっともっとインチキくさい
もうガキっぽい理屈をつけてテキストを家に配りますからね
ある証人のテキストにあったのは
この人間っていうのはね
北極でいても体はすごく守らなきゃ
冷気四十だからね もう生きていられません
でも顔どうですかと 顔は隠さなくてもいいんだと
なぜ顔が凍って人が死なないかと
それがすごい もうそういうふうに
もう神の力ですよ 神がそういうふうに作っているんだよと
それで顔にはいっぱい神経があるんだとか
医学的な話はさんざん
そこら辺はちゃんとした話です
これこれこういうふうな神経が出ていて
ちゃんとこのどんな温度の差にでも耐えられるようにできていてとかね
それで不思議ではないかと
あんたがその神をなぜ信じないかという理屈ですかね
理屈でも何もなりませんだけどね
だってそんなものは自然法則で説明できますからね
例えば裸足でずっと一生歩く人にも
足の裏がものすごい硬くなっても柔らかくなっても
硬い人も柔らかい人もいますけど
ものすごい適応するんですよ
だから試しに まあこれからでも遅くないんだけどね
靴下もまあもう日本の家の作りがね
面倒くさいんだからね
もう履物履かないとね
まあ汚れちゃいますけど
もし履けなくてもいいってことになってみたら
何のことなく もう一ヶ月間二ヶ月間で新しい細胞はもう環境に適応してできちゃいますよ
まあそんなもんですけど
あれで まあそれをそういうことで
まあ生徒として出す その時でも私が考えるのはこういうことね
その人々は勉強する 勉強したところで体の構造に驚く
アホだから 驚くぐらいのこと
それは自然律法なるんだからね
どうったことはないんですけどね
自分の相に驚く サンニャーに驚く
下手サンニャーに それが私です
それが神のからくりですと
それで自分の妄想概念をつなげちゃうと
そちらに論理構成は 因果法則は成り立ってない
そちらには証拠は成り立ってない
私はそう思うだけで だから故に神がいると思うことしか言えません
いるとは言えません だったら
他の人には故に神がいないということも言えるでしょうしね
因果法則で言っちゃうと
もう思うことは不可能ですよ
これだからこうなりますと
もうそれで何も言えなくなっちゃうんですね
断定的には言えないんですね
だから我々の断定っていうのは断定ではなくて
感情であって 思うことなんですね
サンニャーっていうのはそういうもので
サンニャーは私ですよと
私のものですよと 私の魂ですよと思っちゃう
でも なんでサンニャーが私の魂でないと
後でこの説明来ると思いますけどね
同じ教典で サンニャー毎日増えるでしょうに
そうすると魂も毎日増えることになっちゃうんですね
それで勉強して繰り返したりすると
サンニャー 我々が勉強する知識がすごく安定化するでしょうね
それでサンニャーも訓練によって安定することはできる
訓練しないことによって
勉強もどんどんどんどん薄れていくでしょうね
やがて全部きれいさっぱり忘れちゃうでしょうね
ですから 結局はサンニャーも我々はいろんなデータを入れては増えるんだけど
また他のところで全部もう流れていくでしょうね
それはサンニャーの普通のシステムなんです
だから因果法則なんです
勉強すればサンニャーが増えるんだけど
ある面で増えるとある面で消えていく
この痴呆とか何とかいうのも
サンニャーの機能が壊れた時なんですね
サンニャーの機能が壊れたら痴呆と言うんですね
区別できなくなる だから痴呆の人は決して植物人間じゃないんです
いくらかはサンニャーがあるんです
だから自分ということを知ってますからね
いくらかのことは これは鼻見せて
ああ これおいしいホットドッグやと思う場合もあるかもしれませんだけど
大体もう鼻ぐらいは知ってるでしょうに
それサンニャーですからね
時々それも崩れちゃって
違うサンニャーが入り込んじゃって
鼻なんですけど ホットドッグのサンニャーが入り込んじゃうと
ホットドッグで見えちゃうんです
それで食べちゃうんです
痴呆の人は何で変なものを食べたりするんですか？そういうわけなんです
サンニャーの管理が崩れちゃうんですね
だから 見たものにどんなサンニャーが来て定着してるか分からないんですね
まあ大変なことになっちゃう
自分の子供にもあんた誰ですかと聞く時もあるしね
自分の子供は例えばちょっともう支えてベッドにでも寝かしたら
ご親切に本当にどうもありがとうございます
もう感謝するときもあるし
だからそれはもうサンニャーの方がちょっと崩れてるんだっていうことをみんな嫌がりますけど
面白いんですよ 別に 勘違いするの
私は一人しか知りませんですけどね
ボケた人と 本当に面白いんですよ
飽きないんです だから危険なことだけ
なんとかなんとかね 気をつけてあげて
面倒見た方がいいんじゃないかなと
普通の人よりは飽きないんです
だって何言うかわからないです
その想像力は だから常識の世界から見ればね
大変迷惑ですけどね 電車に乗っていくわけにもいきませんしね
病院に一人で行かせるわけにいきませんし
サンニャーが管理してないんだからね
だから守ってあげなくちゃいかんだけど
めんどくさいめんどくさいではなくて
もう人間に考えられないことっていうのをバンバン言うんだから
もう それ全て主観の世界だから
それで個人差が生まれるでしょ
見ただけでみんな平等だから
それでサンニャーが作ったところで
もう個人ですよ それでみんな個人個人っていうのを成り立ってしまってる
だからそれが私ですよと思っちゃうんですね
仏教で言うのはそれが減ったり増えたりするでしょう
結局は 壊れたりするでしょうに
だから執着するのは もう私だと言ったってもね
言葉上は言ってもいいんだけど
真面目にするなよと 私っていうものは真理としては成り立たないんだと
っていうのは仏教の立場なんですね
サンニャーがいてサンカーラがあって
次に最後にヴィンニャーナかな
次に出てくるべきなのはヴィンニャーナなんですけど
ルーパ ヴェーダナー サンニャー
サンカーラ ヴィンニャーナでしょ
色受想行識なんですね
識って何なのか 随分困ってるでしょ
式の機能は口頭で分かりやすく出してるんです
ヤンピダンディッタン
見たもの スッタン 聞いたもの
ムッタン って何ですかね
ムッタンっていうのは
見たと聞いたと以外の情報の世界
いわゆる嗅いだ 味わった
体で感じたという 3つですね
ヴィンニャータンっていうのはまあ知ったものですね
パッタンっていうのは
まあこれはこれだっていう風に結論に至ったもの
パリエーシタンっていうのは
もう考えて至った結論ですね
アヌビチャレタンマナサ
心でもう探求して得たもの
それがヴィンニャーナなんですね
心が働きなんですね いわゆる見たものについて考えるでしょ
聞いたものについて考えるでしょ
だから耳に触れるのは音だけ
カラスやと言ったのはヴィンニャーナですね
もう結論出しちゃったんだから
カラスだというためには
過去のサンニャーを持ってきて
今の音のサンニャーありますね
それで合わせてみたら
あっ 昔はその同じ音にカラスと言ったんだから
これもカラスだよと 本当はカラスかどうかわからないんだけどね
もうとっくにカラスだと瞬時に決めつけちゃう
その機能がヴィンニャーナの働きなんですね
そうやって人間が自分が見たものを
聞いたものを 感じたものを
考えたものを 思ったもの
論理したもの 推測したもの
そういうものについても
これが私ですよと思ってしまいますと
そんなものも変化するでしょうしね
変わるでしょうし そこでこの立体論
私がいるんだということ
どこから生まれるかというと
この体から生まれる 私が永遠不滅やというのは
単純に体から生まれる妄想概念ですよ
人が死んでも魂は死にませんよとよく言うでしょうに
私は本当に何でそんなもうよくバカバカらしいことを
だって微かな証拠もないで
我々知ってるのは人が死んだそれだけなんですよ
やっぱり死んでも天国で見守ってくれるんでしょうと
でしょうと なんでそんなこと言うんでしょうかね
その場合でもなぜ死んだ人が天国で生きてる時にも見守ってくれなかったのに
死んでからはばあちゃん
じいちゃんがね ずっと守ってくれるんですね
なんでそんなことを思うんですかね
結局は日本の文化で勉強したものでしょ
サンニャーでしょうに
あるいはカンジュ サンカーラ
いわゆる母親かおじいばあちゃんが死んだことはなんとなく悲しい
認めたくない 悲しくて認めたくない場合は
いえ 死んでない 天国にいて守ってるんです
思ったらすごいインチキできるんです
犠牲を ですから これはものすごい徹底的犠牲者ですよ
それで人が死んだら仏だと拝む
泥棒でも自殺したらもうそれから拝む
みんな だからみんな平気でどんな悪いことをでもして平気で自殺する
死ねば仏やと 腰抜けでアホですけど
悪いことしたら それ堂々と立ち向かってね
何とかするのはね 勇気のある人の行動なんですけど
確かに悪いことをしましたと
税金を使わないで ちゃんと情報を出して
これこれこれしましたと言った方がね
何千万の税金がね 残るでしょうね
それを自殺して男になる
そんなものはもう人間がものすごい犠牲だから
そんな思考を作る だからこのサンニャーですね
そんなものは サンニャーかサンカーラ
そこで 5つになるんですね
頭がおかしくなる場所5つあるんですね
それからもう一つ 6ありますからね
ヤン
ピダンディッティッターナンソーローコーソーワッターソーペッチャバビッサーミニッチョーデュオーサッソトーアウパリナーマダンマーサタシサマンパテーワタッサー
ミーティタティーエタンナマエーソーサマンシーエーソーメアッタイサマンパッサー
これでお釈迦様まとめて全ての衆生はゴミ箱に入れるんです
ソーローコーソーアッタ
ローコーっていうのは世界という意味で
世ですよ 仏教でローコーというのは衆生のことなんです
生命のことなんです ソウローコー
世界といえば物質的な世界になりますけど
本当は物質的な世界ではなくて
生命世界なんですね 生命という世界
だから日本語でこの生の生と世という漢字だけ使うと
物理的なものを意味してないでしょ
ですから その漢字だけではいいかもしれませんね
界捨てちゃって 界捨てちゃうと物質的な世界になっちゃいますね
我々世のこと気になるんだと言ったら
別に地球のこと気になるわけじゃないでしょうに
人のことを気になるんだということでしょうに
だからここにはこの生命というものを現代日本語にします
ソウローコー 生命というものが
生命というものありますね
その そのものがあったである
魂 霊魂である いわゆる生命イコール魂
霊魂なんですね いわゆる我々は生命だ生命だというのは
魂にそう言ってるんだよと
霊魂に生命だと言ってるんだよと
という宗教家の話なんです
ソウローコー それはまたインド仏教の哲学ではまたものすごく細かく分析できますけど
これはこのアイデンティカルということで
このライフアンドソウルイズアイデンティカルという
訳すればね 生命と魂というのは同一ものであるという同一論と違うという論二つありますね
それでまた異を唱げているんだという話もあります
それから 生命と魂ってのはまるっきり何の関係もないも同じ
いろいろ楽しい論もあります
それは今日は出てきません
こちらで言ってるのは生命は魂である
霊魂である ごく世の中に一般的にあることでしょうね
みんなよく言ってるでしょうね
生命 魂ですよ 体ではないよ
ただ人っていうのは魂ですよとよく言ってるでしょうね
そこで ソウペッチャバディッサメ
死んだらそれが後 行くんでしょう
ペッチャというのはアフターワールド
ネクストワールド 次の世界に行くんだと
その体が壊れたってでもこの魂が生まれ変わるんだと
生まれ変わってニッチョードゥオ
永遠 ニッチャっていうのは常にあるもの
変わらないもの ドゥオっていうのは絶対的に変わらないって意味で
サッサトーっていうのは
また実体として頑固とあるという
日本語の言葉あるかどうか分かりませんだけどね
サッサタっていうのは哲学の用語なんですね
サッサトーって言った場合は常時のものですね
アヴィパリーナマダンモっていうのは不変なもの
変わらないもの 不変の性質はあるんだと
サッサシタマン 永遠にそのままとどまるであろう
永遠にそのまま天国にいるだろうと
だから人が死んでも その魂が転生して
魂自体が永遠だから 変わらないものだから
常時なものだから ずっと永遠にそちらにいるだろうという考え方
世の中の現代宗教も全部そうでしょうに
ヒンズー教だけ輪廻っていう話があるんだけど
やっぱりこれはヒンズー教を配慮にしてお釈迦様おっしゃってることだからね
とにかく そこでもあの聖者がヨーガをやってヨーガ成就したら
梵天に生まれ変わって永遠になるんだっていう話ですからね
梵天に行けば梵我一如で永遠だよと
でもその教え自体がすごい矛盾ですよ
なぜならば もともと梵我一如でしたけど
梵我一如が二分化にして現象世界を作っちゃったんですね
ですから 今の生命の中に魂があるんだけど
もともと梵我一如でしたんですよ
それで二分化されちゃったんだから
それで我々はもう一度修行して
ヨーガをやって あの成就して
また梵我一如になるんだと
意味がないんですね なっても
だってあの梵我一如奴はがね
本当に信頼できませんだから
また二分化したらどうするんですかね
だからその人々の考え方はもうものすごい単純論理ミスを起こしていました
で そこら辺をお釈迦様は気をつけて批判してますよ
なぜかというと 瞑想すると一体感というのは思えるんです
それには妄想が紛れる
解釈する サンニャーに
サンニャー作って 一体感というのは銃ですよ
一緒ではないかという瞬時に
ああ一緒やと思った瞬間
サンニャーも出てきて
それについてまた過去のサンニャーからもう絡み合って
やっぱりこれが梵我一如やと決めてしまっちゃうんですね
だから修行する人にとっては一体感が生まれるということは
まあごく普通な経験で
それで修行すればするほど一体感また変わるんですね
だからもっとマシに修行してみなさいと
今の一体感と違って違ってる一体感出るでしょう
単なる銃ですよ それに実体あるわけじゃないんですね
それでやけにそれが面白くなってしまっちゃって
ものすごい強烈な執着が生まれてきて
解脱は不可能になってしまいますよ
でも やってみればそういう経験あり得るんだから
その修行の結果を否定したくないんですね
いくらなんでも ですから
まあそこら辺はお釈迦様は気をつけて批判するんですね
だから哲学的な思考だけ取って
もうバカにするんです
真面目に修行する部分はバカにしないです
まあどうせいいことをしているんだから
欲から離れて ねぇ まあ人も殺さないし
窃盗もしないで もう本当に一生懸命持ち物もなくて
森の中に隠れて頑張ってるんだからね
その分はまあ褒めてあげたいんですよ
だからどうせ心に即的な煩悩やら汚れが生まれませんだから
どうせ善行為しているんだから
まあ輪廻転生したっていいところに
まあ梵天みたいなところに生まれ変われると
それには邪魔したくないんです
人が死んで地獄に落ちるよりはね
梵天ぐらいで生まれ変わった方がいいでしょうね
それには邪魔しないんだけど
でもあなた方はバカだと
って言いたいのはね この哲学的に思想だけ抽出させて批判するんですね
だからお釈迦様 えらい微妙なんです
その私が死んだら永遠不滅で
そのものが私の魂であるという考え方
それは六つですね そこで仏弟子たちが
ああもう時間飛んじゃった
今日終わると思っちゃったんですけど
まあ元旦すごかったね
仏弟子たちが完全にそんなこと思わない
ただそれだけ 同じこと繰り返しなんですけど
仏弟子たちではなくて
まちの先生にあって まちに物事を勉強した人が
まちに論理ができてるんだからね
体は体で見るんですよ
ですから もうちょっとマシになればいいっていうか
あの真面目になればいいと
で 銃は銃であって変化するでしょうに
これが私の魂でも私でもなんでもないんだと
考えたものもね 単なる変化するんであってね
私も私の魂でもなんでもないんだよと
そこで私というこの体が死んじゃったらね
人々が死んじゃったらね
輪廻転生するのは魂ではないんだと
というふうなことで もう何にもとらわれないと
そう えーワンサモヌパッセとアサティ
ね パリタッセティ そこはすごいキーワードなんですね
アサティね パリタッセティは
これはまあまあインドのね
哲学思想を背景にして言ってる言葉で
ヒンドゥー教はサッという一言葉に求めております
サッ リアリティ 真理 実体
我 サッです サッイコール我です
サッっていうのはこのブーッというルートから
いわゆるあるというルートからね
まあ作れますけどね うん
だからアサティっていうのはもうウに対するモウなんですよ
何もないと でもモッという言葉は使わない
そうするとまた違ういろいろ問題が出てくる
ですから サッに対して非サッにするだけ
サッではありませんと
モッといえば全く別な思考だったことになります
まあそこら辺は難しいんだからちょっとやめますけど
このサッではない 実体がありませんということが分かっても
ね パリタッセティ 動揺すること何もない
で まあそこら辺で終了いたします
ああ 難しかったです